- DRock and I are going to
Connecticut, right DRock?
- Right.
- Either you understand
the intent of this company
or you don't, like I just
want it, this is binary,
I don't care about these details,
nobody in this fucking
company is gonna exist
if they don't understand
what the fuck I'm doing.
Nobody, zero,
like there's, like I'm just,
I have zero tolerance for
anybody who doesn't understand,
do you understand?
Like let me save you guys time,
(name redacted) will not
make it at VaynerMedia.
I know that now.
So, cool, I just don't
want to waste time here
on this conversation, either
you fucking understand
that my intent is always right,
that we're the best fucking
intentional company of all time,
and that we want to do
everything that's right
for every single person,
or you do not.
And any of your actions that
think that you've forgot
or that we've changed
or anything else,
puts you in a
fucking vulnerable spot
because I will not tolerate it
for a very long period of time.
I'm, I have zero tolerance
for the cliché thing,
like we've changed, it's inevitable.
Oh, here it is.
Cynicism is unacceptable.
Please let them know,
we hired 150 people,
we fired 50 people and
I'll fire everybody,
I don't need any of them.
I just have no tolerance
for this, I really don't.
This is annoying.
I'm not in the
slapping wrist business,
I'm in the cutting
their fucking hearts
out of their bodies business.
There's no kool-aid, it's the water,
it's what we do,
you know what I mean?
Like kool-aid comes from that
dude fucking tricking people
and killing them.
There's no fucking kool-aid,
it's our water,
it's our fucking water.
Hey, how are you?
I'm so good, I just
want to take two minutes
and just congratulate you,
like this is obviously
such a big deal.
You're such a beneficiary
of the world that we're
trying to build, which is,
it doesn't matter how many
years you've been working
or where you come from but like
if you're great, you get
opportunities and I think
you're great and
I'm just so proud of you.
It's really awesome.
I'm super pumped for you,
and keep up the good
work and keep me close,
you know, like I'm super
willing and capable
of helping you.
Alright, awesome, you're welcome.
(blows kiss)
Talk to you later, bye bye.
(light music)
Look at this, huh, cool.
Cool, right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
What happened that day?
Why were you there?
- It was South By 2008 or '09,
I can't remember which year
and Mark gave one
of the big keynotes.
- A lot of the focus
has been on things that
we as a company aren't
necessarily as focused on
and the thing that we are
trying to do at Facebook
is just help people
connect and communicate
more efficiently.
- And I gave a keynote.
The first part of it is that
most people in the wine
industry are douche bags.
(laughter, cheering, applause)
I'm just less of a douche bag,
that's why people like me.
Just talking about where the
world was gonna go, you know.
It was so obvious to
me that Zucks was gonna
build one of the biggest
companies in the world.
- Is there something
about this bigger vision
of where Facebook's
going that naturally
conflicts with privacy,
is this something
that's gonna keep
cropping up for you guys?
- We need to give
people complete control
over their information, alright,
people need to be able to say
exactly who they want to share
each piece of information
they're sharing.
So for example,
cell phone numbers, right?
I think the most recent stat
is something like 20 or 25%
of people on Facebook have
their cell phone number shared
and the reason why they're able
to do that is they can say,
I only want to share
this with my friends.
Where if I were to share
it with 60 million people,
then you wouldn't want to do that,
so actually giving people
very granular control
over who they share
information with
actually allows those connection
and that communication
to take place.
- He's just so cool, it's
just so cool to like,
I think about like my
great-great-grandchildren,
if there was a picture
in the house of like
my great-great-great-grandfather
or whatever
or my great-great-great-grandmother
hanging with Thomas Edison or, you know,
like it's just cool, that's
gonna be a fun narrative
of like being right about
where the world's going
and to be very frank,
whether it's meditation
or virtual reality or
things of that nature,
I plan on continuing
my ability to
spot strategically
where consumers
are gonna be going,
where people
and spot the people
that are talented
and changing that
and creating that world.
I think a lot of times
I talk about my hustle,
and my work ethic and I almost
subconsciously undermine
my strategic ability,
I don't talk about my smarts.
I almost don't even
respect my smarts myself,
which is probably
why I don't project it,
but I definitely am far more
strategic about my business
decisions and where I'm
going and how I'm going about
doing it, I think my actions
speak to my strategy.
A lot of people are like, "Hey
Gary, why don't you put out
"more strategy content,"
and I laugh at you.
I laugh at you because
I say to myself,
if you actually understood strategy,
you would pay much more
attention to what I'm doing
versus than what I'm saying.
I've recognized one of my
talents is to use my words
and my storytelling abilities
to help so many of you
get started or continue to fight
and I think that my actions,
the way that I put out my content,
how do I do it, when do
I do it, why do I do it,
where do I do it, what am I making,
is it video, is it pictures, is it quotes,
am I tagging, what time am I posting?
Why am I embedding
YouTube videos right now
versus native on DailyVee?
Because it's getting
more organic reach.
Why is that happening?
My actions speak to my strategy
and so for a lot of you that
are looking for more strategic
content I would implore you
to start understanding that
strategy is better to be,
if you want to learn strategy,
if you want to
become more strategic,
if you want to be
smarter about things,
I recommend that you don't
look for people like me
to tell you how to do it,
I recommend that you learn
how to watch people like me
and how we do it.
I'm at Foxwoods giving a
keynote to some executives
from Madison Square Garden,
should be a lot of fun,
looking forward to it.
I'm gonna start
doing more characters,
Grandma Vee hopes you have
the best day of the year.
Love you.
I just want to say that
in Grandma Vee's day,
we hustled harder.
You kids are fucking soft!
In my day, a business was
something that made money,
not something that raised money.
(blows raspberry)
That's the meme!
- [Host] It's my grand pleasure
to introduce our featured
speaker, Gary Vaynerchuk.
(applause)
- Thank you, brother.
Thanks for having me.
Everybody here has a really
good thought and opinion
on Facebook, Instagram,
and Snapchat advertising,
yet 98% of you have
never placed an ad
or understood what's actually
happening underneath there,
so we live in a world of
headline reading ecosystem,
versus lack of practionership
and there's an
enormous opportunity.
I sit in executive meetings
and in business meetings
24/7/365 and I watch
smart people who know
what's actually happening in society
really just shoot complete bullshit
because they know for
inside their organization,
this is what's acceptable,
this is what's respected
by the upper brass,
and this is what's not
gonna get you in trouble.
What happens is, my friends,
is this is what happens
during times of innovation
and that is what's happening right now.
Shit's gonna hit the fan, the
future Fortune 500 companies
that you're gonna be looking
to work for a decade from today
are gonna be looking
at your body of work
and the people that
were in that room,
that go on to get other jobs,
are gonna be judging you for
being historically incorrect
in your strategy and so you
have so much more upside
to actually say what you believe
because that's been
the funny part, right?
I was just at Cannes,
the advertising festival,
I sit on these panels,
I talk this bullshit,
everybody else goes
he's wrong, TV growth
is better than ever, (mumbles).
They all gang up on me
'cause they're all in
the agency holding companies,
and like fuck this guy, right?
And then at 3:00 in the morning,
while we're all drinking
Rosé at the Carlton,
they come up to me and they're like,
psssst, you're fucking right, right?
There's not a single person
that's capable of being in this room
that doesn't know I'm right,
that we're spending tons of
fucking money on dumb shit.
It's just that everybody's
in the same ecosystem.
Thank you for having me.
(applause)
- We know you're a
basketball player and a fan.
- Yes!
- Season ticket holder.
- DRock, get this, yes!
- Nice job, that was great.
- Thanks, man.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it seemed like they
got some value out of it.
Grandma Vee just
wants to remind you
that in my day, everybody
said radio is king
and I said this TV
thing is gonna be big.
(blows raspberry)
(laughing)
Really well brother, how are you?
Good, yeah, so tell me
what's on your mind?
She needs to realize, like,
she doesn't know
what she's talking about.
We need to be her friend
sooner than later.
Because I'm the toughest,
I'm the easiest and
then the hardest
when I get to that place.
Like, I'm the easiest until I decide
and then there's no going back.
Yeah, I mean, but you know,
that's silly because if you're right,
if you're wrong even once,
then it doesn't, then it
eliminates everything.
That's what people
don't understand,
you're underestimating optimism.
If you're right
seven out of ten times,
but you didn't allow
somebody that came in
that was gonna be a superstar,
because you went that route,
it's a lot easier to go that route,
you know what I mean?
Or reverse, I mean like,
if you start really auditing,
I promise you some of the people
that you were excited about
have not materialized
in the way we wanted to.
What's not a crap shoot
is creating an environment
that allows people that
could go one way or the other
to thrive and another crap shoot is
eliminating people that
don't fucking get it.
But I think there's a
difference between thin ice
and the beginning of a
process that gets to thin ice.
Like kind of, you know what I mean,
the beginning of a
process where the see-saw
is not going in the other direction.
The see-saw went from
you're sitting on the ground
and you know,
that means you're winning
'cause you weigh more than
the thing on the other side,
now the see-saw's even and
since you were starting
by sitting on the ground
and the see-saw's now even,
that's not a good place,
that means it's heading
in the wrong direction.
You want the see-saw
to flip over your head,
you know what I mean?
Hey brother.
Good, I'm super not pumped
about this whole situation.
Like I'm not happy,
and I have to unwind it and
I'm not pointing fingers,
but I'm not happy.
Thanks brother, bye.
There's no competition here,
I've been selling shit while
Gary was still in diapers.
It's all Granny.
(laughing)
Hello ladies, hello.
I'm good guys, how are you?
Tell me, before we get started,
I'd love to get a quick
three to four minute update?
I would say, I'm not against it,
I just want you guys to know
I'm very sensitive to it right?
I'm an old dog in business
and I've seen it happen
so many times and I don't
want to get into a place where
by circumstance, we can't
have the kind of relationship
I want to continue to have.
I want to be very upfront to
tell you what makes me nervous
but I definitely don't
want to restrict anything
and I do feel like as
long as I'm communicating,
you'll communicate with me
and we can figure anything out
in the future, you know what I mean?
Francesca asks,
between starting a podcast
and starting a web
series other than talent,
what are the factors to consider?
A lot, I mean talent is the variable,
if you're not talented enough,
there's no tactics,
there's no growth hacking,
there's no strategy
that's gonna help you,
you have to be worth
listening to, worth watching.
The other things to
consider are distribution.
So there's the
quality of the content
and then there's distribution.
I actually think that a lot
of people think I'm talented
or that I have "it,"
I actually think my distribution
strategies have been better
than my actual talent.
You know, doing YouTube
early on, then Twitter,
you know, the way we
do Facebook video now,
even this piece of content,
I think my distribution
strategies have been strong
and have been a
variable in my success
in the way that I think
there's a lot of people
that could be a model or
somebody that's funny on a show,
it's just who gets picked
and who gets the awareness,
so I think you're in
control your distribution
more than you
are in your talent,
so I think the
biggest thing, Francesca,
that all of you have
to pay attention to is,
where are you
distributing your content,
is your content
relevant to that platform,
how do you hack that
platform to be somebody
that gets awareness, those are
things that I most focus on.
The climate for fundraising
has gotten very difficult
which is why you're seeing a
lot of things starting to fold.
And then this is a very
narrow, niche thing,
so I think one of the ways
to think about this is
I was thinking a lot
about what to talk about
in this call, one of the
things that's running through
my mind is what would
the world look like
if you did a whole lot of 50,
100,000, and $200,000 checks?
One of the things you
should contemplate is
how much do you need to raise
that gives you enough
runway to kind of
build a meaningful
business in your mind
and how do you piece it
together with individuals
maybe instead of an institution?
Good to hear your voice man,
looking forward to seeing you.
Oh I appreciate it.
I'm looking forward to
visiting you there
on your home turf
and I'm glad that we
got to do this call
and I love you and I hope
you have a great fourth
and I'll see you soon.
Please feel free to be over
zealous with our relationship
if that can help you get a gig.
I'm thrilled to get on
the phone with anybody,
any recruiting firm,
any CEO of an agency,
and vouch for you and I think
you can throw around my name
a little bit more aggressively
than you think you
might've been able to.
Thanks brother, no worries man,
I wish you well, take care.
Bye-bye.
How do you treat former employees
is just as important as how you
treat your current employees.
Not exactly as important,
but right there.
Congratulations, I've seen
the pictures and everything
and it's so amazing.
How you doing?
Feels crazy, right?
And scary.
Oh my God, like the first two months
I would literally go
into Mischa's room
and check if she was breathing,
I was scared crapless.
If you have a good balance
of understanding you as an
executive and a decision
maker and a leader,
and you understand how
to read your competitors
and how to read your consumers,
using those data points,
what are they doing?
How are they acting?
What are they spending money on?
What are they creating?
If you're a fast follower
to those data points,
you can oftentimes have success.
And more importantly, everybody
who's reading this article
has different businesses
and different markets
with different competitors
and different moments in time
with different upsides,
that's the beauty,
it's like being a great fisherman,
like you can't explain it, you
just have a feel for the rod.
I'm not a fisherman, I'm just
looking at a big body of water
which led me to
create that analogy.
(electronic music)
(plane flying overhead)
Alright Granny Vee, you
think more people are gonna
screenshoot your
snap over mine?
I sure do you little
young whippersnapper,
I'm gonna prove it right now.
The next two snaps, pick
either me or Gary's snap.
(laughs)
You like that?
Granny Vee versus GaryVee.
Here we go.
She's huge.
- [DRock] She's won.
- No, no, it's early.
Ooh, I'm winning.
I know, it's early.
Oh you're right, I got
90 more views than her.
Than her, I'm literally
competing with her
as if she's real, I'm
already freaking out.
Oh it's not even close.
She's up 51, 31.
Heading to see the boys.
Seeing my two brother in laws,
my best friend, my cousin,
one of my good friends, Jeff,
who's manager at Wine Library.
Should be a fun day, a
little baseball game action,
then into the holiday weekend,
so good stuff, good day.
Fun to give a talk, bunch of calls,
lot of intensity, lot
of running the business
through the phone,
a lot of operational stuff,
HR stuff, client stuff,
so good, productive day.
You know, also navigated a lot
of business through my phone
while you weren't watching
and the emergence of a true
superstar, a once in a generation
superstar, Grandma Vee.
So all in all, quality, quality effort.
Wishing all of you a great
Fourth of July weekend,
I know this will
probably air after that,
so I hope you had a good one.
(R&amp;B music)
Nice pants, B-Dub.
New pants?
I'm being serious!
No, no, I really like your pants.